yeah hello welcome to a new video and
I'll play a 15 minute game for a change
but as usual I don't know what opening
let's say Sicilian yeah 15 minute game I
haven't done those for a while so um I
think it's good good change
so I'm let's see what is playing for D
forgives us so usually here means this
miss Maurel gambit I'm not quite sure
what what is good again at this okay
let's let's take first very often I'd
also just play d3 here we turn the pawn
but okay I'd like to see what happens if
I actually grabbed the pawn
yeah usually White has gotten some
compensation in this opening because of
the in the c4 which can be used and
somewhat slightly quicker development
still always a surprise to me that this
should be a valid opening but okay there
are quite some some books written and so
on so it's maybe not terribly bad if
I've is a move that I have a hard time
understanding to be sure to be honest
here
we know Knight f6 this is a move but
okay I cannot take with the night yeah
9595 g65 Bishop f7 and it's yeah time
for a very long face so um I could I
could take with the pawn Queen D 898 but
then you might have a move like Knight
to d5
95 96 it's a bit not sure
looks a bit tricky so what if I play
just is 60m don't take the pawn if he
takes on d6 Queen d6 I think I won quite
some time beam okay let's play this
I also mmm-hmm I think I threatened now
to take the pawn or even defy this sort
of a threat if the close position should
really give white or no compensation if
I get to play d5 I think you might need
to take No yeah note that I couldn't
play Bishop g4 because of Bishop takes
f7 so I'm pretty much it was the decider
between taking on our play 6 maybe I
could have taken but it doesn't look
like super nice position to play taking
Queen takes Knight x95 was yeah a bit
annoying c7 check was threatened so I'm
not sure what I would have done against
this so I think maybe this was better
okay so it's developing the play Bishop
d7 no he might take on his 7 I take on
d6 so I'm not sure that I want that so
um
what else could I do f6 looks very loose
on a move like Queen a 5 he might even
take on g6 so Queen c7 yeah
yeah he's got quite a good development
here for the palm not sure if this is
enough very much possible I mean I have
three pieces still on my initial squares
he's got everything out it's not yeah
but it's not like that I'm weakened so
much yeah so it's hard to believe that
he could get something quickly yeah so
should I check here after the check
would need to block the check which
would be helpful for me to to speed up
development or play a king which he most
liked he doesn't want to do
okay so we retreated mmm what now
and I would take Quinn takes then 96
might be problem but how to how to avoid
this move oh wait um just a second here
what about what about twin to f4
tweet to f4 maybe you know this is
either an entirely do tech move for a
great one okay
yeah it'd take the night now make use of
the pin here so I cannot take the Queen
of course an idea that there the night
is hanging and he needs to react somehow
if you take some before I can take a
phone and win a piece it's a check and
both bishops are hanging so they cannot
take on before also so maybe he really
needs to go Queenie to here and then I
would capture on d2 and play Knight f6
and this should be quite okay
yeah this move made sure that even
there's no night appearing on d6 so
maybe it was good after all but it's
good to be skeptical about so
fancy-looking moves like Sweeney for
maybe it's strong but it can easily
become complete completely moronic so
what now should I take on D to apply
Knight f6 maybe 9 f6 s bet I am
could be this is some sort of tempo him
he needs to react to this and Queen
takes e4 Knight takes d4 threatened and
if he takes on before with the bishop I
can even consider Queen takes a form so
maybe he needs to take my stall
recapture with the Queen yeah and
exactly so now it doesn't get a night to
you for which would have been a problem
otherwise maybe this night is gone now
yeah white still has some quite good
pieces he can play 95 stuff like that
and my bishop on c8 is still a bit but
limited Wow
yes uh moves really if you if you're a
bit stunned long castles Wow
yeah okay I think I should wait first
check if there's something something
possible immediately but it's hard to
believe without the King being safe
first
I mean lung cancer it seems like like
very risky here on the C file and so on
I have b5 there should be seven coming
and so on and maybe this I could have
played something more yeah
energetic then cathodes but b5 is pretty
serious business here b5 we should be
seven Queen f4 I mean I've just I'm just
attacking this king here
yeah now I can at least play a queen
check Queen f5 queen g6 okay but I want
to get every piece into play first the
500 b7
okay Bishop e7 now should be good
so hearing one possibility also Bishop
d5 now taking the bishop trying to get
to position like Bishop d5 Bishop d5 95
it will also still give this check here
Queen f5 or g6 not bad okay try to to
make this transformation the knight on
d5 is obviously very nicely positioned
after after his taking on d5 yeah this
is just a demonstration I mean it
doesn't do anything it's quite some time
until he gets a real attack here so
maybe first the rook to the seafoam
g5 okay yeah the question is if I give
this check now to play something like
Queen d3 do I really want to exchange
Queens I don't think I want oh yeah but
this should be should be good anyway if
he you know I'm moving moving the King
would have been you know risky is too
friendly so what no I mean I can just
take with them the very nice endgame
only question is if that's maybe
something clearly better I'm not sure so
okay I'll just exchange
so now you can try to double up the
seafoam or can I could also push the
queenside pants all not bad I think I go
for the C file first it can't hurt to to
have this file maybe he needs to play
rook c1 now then I could play with a to
c7 okay he try some attack here but now
threatening Roxy to and I think he needs
to you know you need to react to this
so furthered wants the Queen side on it
says something something better
laser taking b5
yeah an estimated this a bit really
I'm sorry this at least wasn't the most
exact way to blame
so would this move our offer to return
the pawn could play not be three now
attacking also a5 the madea's rook c4
Knight a5 through k4 and then before
okay it doesn't even go for this
you know not much choice
yeah this wasn't exactly the greatest
technical clay ever the problem is that
I mean from my performance idea what I
did here wasn't so great
the problem is that you know this King
is very active and this might be a
problem
my King is still on g8 ends do nothing
it could be really really really
difficult to to get something here I
mean I could also simply be worse it's
possible I'm trying not to play 93 if he
plays King bee 593 I get P to listen
share in an exchange okay he tries to
maybe bring the Knight to c3
hmm yeah of course you can do that
well this was really not a garbage
woulda caladium oh my
hmm yeah my king is not playing maybe I
should have activated it instead of this
move all right it's going back
so maybe grab the tempo at least the
texture the pointer can play have six
and then maybe try to play King have
seven stuff like this okay the issue is
tweaking liking to be five and they
cannot rescue the power
and my knight doesn't have any squares
gets better and better
yeah I think he needs to take now yeah
man I distract him this was really
terrible
okay surprisingly advances okay it could
have just taken a play King v5 and what
is winning I think so what now should I
protect e5 I can also play now good
night before which at least should
secure me a decent position if he takes
e5 I've got 93 actually and when the
b-pawn would be quite good reply if for
that he goes king c4 back can i play
king of seven activate hmm
okay I'll gamble on this I cannot
calculate this to the end
the question is white now goes back king
c4 b5 takes King b3 takes the knight I
mean this is a couple of moves in the
meantime I know I'm only 5 and push f4
f4 f3 and stuff maybe I can promote one
of those pawns ok and now it gets
it's really weird can capture protect
this
now what is he doing is he planning to
play h5 maybe
okay I try to go 93 now so queen 93 now
if he double captures on g6 I could also
just take so not especially bad but I
lose both pawns and I just have the H
pawn 93 it takes on g6 H takes King
takes F form king of five
f3 f3 and e3 year but he can still stop
all this
of course I can also just play 95 check
oh yeah this is this is so much better
why didn't I see this before I have no
idea that's your phone
what's the idea okay I cannot believe
this year I just strap it to now then
I've got the a porn 93 mp3 taking f2
yeah this online game yeah okay this
whole and game wasn't exactly exactly
great play by me and I need to turn down
the volume place resins of those
messages let me do this now before I
forget it again and this is this is just
terrible sounds turn down the volume a
bit
yeah played this end game really yeah
the whole procedure had to this I mean a
fight was just was just just was just
terrible I really underestimated this 94
b3 stuff if I just play play normal
moves I should be just a pawn up with
about no compensation and here it
actually gets a bit tricky maybe here
should have gone before I was a bit will
be afraid of a form and then might be
three but I have not been success of
myself so maybe before here and from
here I should have taken of course and
yeah it here it gets really tricky I
mean not taking here and see - it's
really really terrible I need to take
that that he needs to recapture with the
night and then I can keep one pair of
rooks on the board and I have nope no
problems really
but without rooks it's it's getting more
than tricky need to play here and then
he can can do all kinds of stuff I mean
now it's it's clear that whitus is quite
good here and this is of course really
somebody insane idea okay
now I can actually go here but it gets
it gets totally crazy later I think this
is not sure what I what I thought there
beginning here it gets very nice for
white yeah and here this is a huge
problem here he can just take on f6 and
this is much better
I mean you're taking here on f6 would be
would be excellent for white I can maybe
look at this quickly here he takes him
recaptures and then he just she just
grabbed this night I completely
committed suicide in this game I can try
stuff like that here
I can just rescue this thing yeah and in
the end white is got here two weeks
responds yeah really
don't don't don't take this as a sort of
example out to play the endgame alright
thanks for watching anyway and yeah I
don't think I can make another video
because football or soccer if you in do
yes is coming up so this will be my
video for today I guess yeah yeah
talk talk to you soon I guess on Sunday
tomorrow I've got a huge over the board
blitz event so keep fingers crossed for
that okay bye